- So we talked about "Death on the Nile"
but we should also mention the other movie
that Kenneth wrote and directed "Belfast"
So it's about your childhood, right?
- It is. Yeah.
- Because Jamie played you, right?
- Jamie Dornan, And was
a bit beautiful actor,
and you talked to Jamie, of course.
- Yeah, We interviewed
about it. Yeah yeah yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah. And so this
is about a moment in my life
when I was nine years old,
when from a really
beautifully harmonious moment,
in my life, we lived in a street full of
Catholics and Protestants violence visited
and suddenly what was a playground
became a kind of fortress.
And our family had to negotiate our way
through a very difficult time
as so many other families did
at that moment.
And so, the film is partly about
how do you find wherever you get it,
the joy, the laughter, the fun the family,
- Yeah.
- the romance so, you know, all the things
all the coping mechanisms step by step
that in difficult times
when change is happening,
traumatic change sometimes,
How do you find a way to just
love those who are near you
and feel that, and allow
that to sustain you
and take you through to some
kind of, you know, comfort
- It's interesting.
It's so great, but it's interesting how
it's a different story,
but everybody's been going
through something so traumatic
for the last two years.
So there's so many, like you say
there's so many coping mechanisms
and it was just interesting,
you know, to watch the film
and then also like realize
what everybody's been going through
financially, emotionally,
- Sure , yeah.
- mental health
like all of that,
it's quite a bold thing, I think
to be able to be so comfortable
in letting everyone in
- Well, I don't know about
how comfortable I was
but I felt like it was
necessary as you say,
- okay.
- It was something about
the unsettled nature
of the way we were living.
- Yeah.
- Suddenly the future was uncertain
when we were all locked down,
- Uh mm
- We just didn't know
whether any kind of normal
lives would be returned to.
We literally missed people.
We were able to understand
how much we loved people
how much we needed human contact,
- Touch, just touch. Yeah
- Yeah, exactly.
- So weird!
- This sort of tactile
nature, how, you know
all missing a hug, you know?
- Yeah.
- And so that, I think that
strips a few layers of skin
off you and you go back to moments when,
at least in my life,
when you were facing the same thing
and you found a way to
reestablish that contact and
and sort of understand
how simple the, you know,
the kind of, and the beauty of love
and human contact,
particularly in families can be
- That We can take for granted as well.
- Yeah. That we do.
And, and so this was a film that was about
I wanted to go back and say,
thank you to my parents.
- Yeah.
- I wanted to pay tribute
to all the kind of sacrifices they made.
And every parent makes
every day of the year
and every part of the
world for their kids.
- Absolutely.
- And they do, thank you.
- Yeah.
- And I thought, you know what
I'm gonna buy the vulnerability.
And so, as a result
across the course of working on that film
I've been a sort of emotional
wreck most of the time.
- No, that's what what
I was gonna say too.
- But it's okay.
It's better out than in
- No, that's how I write,
like, people are like,
oh man, you wrote about that.
I'm like I had to, there was no option.
- Yeah.
- Like, cause sometimes I feel
like you have to get it out.
- Yeah.
- Especially artists.
It's like how we process.
I feel like, have you ever been like
especially the last two
years, wasn't it crazy?
Like just, a lot of people
that I know that are
strong individuals really
suffered like either relationships
or just with self-love or like just jobs
Like everything was weird.
- Well, I feel very lucky that
we, you know, we were okay.
My parents who live in San Diego are 95
and my mom is just about to turn 93.
They've been married 71 years.
- Oh My God!
- Amazing!
- Bravo! Bravo!
- Whaaat?! and that doesn't exist anymore.
- I know.
And they're still
in the same house that we
moved into when I was 10.
- Whaaaat??!1
- So I have to say not
seeing my parents for a while
because of course, we all stayed away
until we were all vaccinated,
boosted, tested, yada, yada
I really missed them.
And I missed, you know,
the rest of my family and what
you were saying about a hug
and just being in contact, you really
see how much we need that during
this past couple of years.
- Uh um
- So yeah. It was tough.
Tough for a lot of people.
- Yeah. No, but the connection
thing is, is so funny.
I never realized how much
I mean I'm like Elaine from Seinfeld.
I knew this like, I'm
like a very touchy person.
- Yes, yes.
- But like even when I'm like
happy or sad or whatever,
but I've never realized how
much I missed like just touch.
- Yes, yes.
It was just very crazy.